build-it draw play Vsauce Kevin here
with some of the coolest creations from
extraordinary people this is VP build
valeriano fatica carves fruits and
vegetables on his YouTube channel or
delano production using a variety of
knives and scrapers he turns watermelons
into unicorns
pumpkins into the Joker and even uploads
tutorials for budding fruit carvers like
how to turn a lemon into a mouse
Matthias Wandel is a prolific builder
with the remarkable YouTube channel
focused on woodworking his videos tend
to pair up with a more detailed
explanation on his website so you'll be
building tiny boxes a wasp sucking
machine or even a wooden combination
lock in no time
this guy is the definition of builded
team lab built an interactive flower
garden that smells different depending
on what time of day it is and also moves
as you move the floating garden has over
2,300 living flowers that rise up in a
circle around the viewer making them
feel like they're at the center of the
garden at all times and it was built to
evoke certain Zen teachings of
interconnectedness draw Malaysian
artists hangi created a giant portrait
using 20,000 bags of tea it took two
months to finish and depicts a man
preparing a famous type of tea called
tea tarik which means pulled tea honey
said she created the piece because she
wanted to recreate an everyday seem
unique to the culture of Malaysia
Amy Shackleton is a painter who uses
condiment bottles instead of brushes by
using a rotating canvas water and
squeeze bottles she paints colorful
works that bring together the rigid
straight lines of a city with the
organic movements of nature and she
hopes her paintings inspire
conversations about the cohabitation of
humans and the environment and now for
the work of Julia Dillon a freelance
sci-fi and fantasy artists from
California
[Music]
[Music]
lorraine Lutz has an ongoing series
called paintings for ants she plans to
paint 100 miniature pictures this year
and picks her subjects based on what day
of the week it is like microcosm mondays
or free fridays she's auctioning off
each painting on instagram so if you
know of any ants that love art let them
know play it ukulele underground teaches
you how to play songs on the ukulele
with the aid of live performance and
helpful animations conspiracy is a group
of multimedia artists that create
graphic demos off-screen colonies is an
audiovisual exploration of imagined
world that they built to showcase their
abilities
[Music]
finally the mixed-media music video for
Fantasia
bifur voice features a young girl
experiencing what may or may not be a
dream
inspiration also comes from you Vsauce
creative fan showcase first up is
where's Wilder with PO let's go
[Music]
Amin is using connects to improve the
mobility of Parkinson's patients using
the motion capture to monitor their
symptoms and improve their mobility
colas Navarro created Petra Nome your
animal metronome an app that's a fun way
to do music training as you keep time
with the meow bark or quack universe is
a youtube channel by Psylocke hosted by
an alien giving its perspective on the
universe use Earth's variety as a gauge
and try to imagine the diversity of all
of these creatures and they're
fascinating existences here's the band
harriet with their song irish margaritas
Kika creates abstract artwork driven by
a love of travel and nature using a
combination of non-traditional materials
and photography
submit your bidipis to be DP at Vsauce
comm or share them with everyone on
Twitter with hashtag be DP if you need
even more inspiration check out guy's
new show over on we sauce this world of
ours which is a laid-back look at some
of the sweetest submissions from real
vsauce fans so click here to go check
that out right now and as always thanks
for watching
I think I should go
you